all right back here on the ingram angle  i told you i had a confession to make  and it involves our ongoing annual  debate  raymond and i real versus fake christmas  trees  i've always had a real christmas tree  because why raymond  why you i love the smell natural  it's nature smell and i've always warned  you because the shots on those trees  when they fall they can catch in your  dogs  because of the rush of this particular  year and the difficulty  i got a fake tree i got a fake tree and  i feel terrible about it i have a fake  tree  you raymond you won one side of the  debate no  you won this year so please but i'm back  with real next year  okay but it is a lot easier we'll see i  might add and i have a puppy so  no shots down the you know what and  coming out the other side for the puppy  it took me 10 years but i convinced you  all right merry christmas  raymond thank you so much